[Musik]
unsere rufe sind in den letzten jahren
lauter geworden
die rufe von uns frauen nach rechten
schossen und respekt bewegungen wie nie
tun haben millionen von uns auf die
straße gebracht in aufgezeigt dass
männer und frauen immer noch ungleich
behandelt werden was die welt braucht
sind sichtbare frauen mächtige frauen
sowie die deutsche
verteidigungsministerin annegret kramp
karrenbauer die einnahme von rund
200.000 beteiligt
der größte gender gap den ich in meinem
berufsalltag begegne ist die abwesenheit
von frauenbundes ist die tatsache dass
frauen nach wie vor deutlich schlechter
bezahlt sind als die männlichen kollegen
frauen wie die schwere koloss die eine
der letzten männerdomänen aufmischt die
pornografie
wenn wir über sex reden dann gibt es
auch heute noch einen großen unterschied
zwischen männern und frauen die so
genannte orgasmus kluft und frauen
länderspiels hecking die sich alleine
gegen sexismus der schweizer
medienbranche stellt und gewinnt wenn
ich ein zeitung lese da sind frauen noch
immer dekoration und
spielen vor allem der werbung mitunter
stürmisch diese frauen spielen die
hauptrolle in dieser serie
weil sie aktiv dazu beitragen dass die
welt zu einem gerechteren ort wird sowie
dass viele von uns versuchen auch ich
mein name ist patrizia laeri ich bin
ökonomen unternehmerin und journalistin
unser vorsorgesystem benachteiligt
menschen die weniger verdienen oder
teilzeit arbeiten und das sind vor allem
frauen
ich bin aber auch mutter erkennen die
belastungen die berufstätige frauen mit
kindern aushalten müssen
als wirtschaftsjournalistin bin ich auf
die einzige frau in einem raum voller
männlicher kollegen und darf man
interviewpartner sind oft männer sie
allein erklären uns die welt und darauf
habe ich keine lust mehr
in dieser folge will herausfinden welche
rolle medien für die gleichberechtigung
erfahrung spielen ob sie die
geschlechter klischees zementieren oder
diese aufbrechen und was frauen
tagtäglich in den sozialen medien
verlieben
[Musik]
die geschichten von yolanda spiels
hegglin anna wieczorek und ziege maurer
liefern mögliche antworten und um sie
dreht sich dieser film
[Musik]
an einem verregneten montag morgen bin
ich mit rosanna kröte der macherin
dieses films unterwegs im zug hier in
dieser kleinen stadt in der
zentralschweiz lebt yolanda spiels
hitler mit welchen gefühlen triffst du
dich denn jetzt mit jolanda also als
journalistin und als vertreter der zunft
ein bisschen glaube ich einer der
größten medienskandale die ich erlebt
habe in meiner laufbahn auch als
journalistin und ich weiß gar nicht so
ist das auch in einem anderen land hätte
passieren können
also alles noch vorm tor passiert
jolanda spiels hegglin diesen namen
kennen in der deutschschweiz die
allermeisten leute seid 2014 verdienen
eidgenössische medien richtig viel geld
mit ihr 2015 war sie sogar die meisten
googelte frau der schweiz
und das kam so im winter 2014 besuchte
länderspiels hecking als frisch gewählte
grüne kantonsrätin eine feier der zuger
regierung dort geschah etwas das ihr
leben für immer verändern und die
schweiz auf jahre beschäftigen sollte
jolanda erwachte am nächsten morgen mit
erinnerungslücken und
unterleibsschmerzen alles oder komisch
alles wurde neben ich habe die leute
nicht mehr erkannt und dann nach zehn
minuten weiß ich nichts mehr aufgewacht
bin ich zu hause
morgens um 8
nach ihrer untersuchung im krankenhaus
gelangte diese information an die medien
wie genau es bis heute nicht geklärt
sagte london ich glaube ich hätte diese
geschichte nicht mal meinen eltern
erzählt und ich glaube das wäre es
gewesen sich für mich behauptet das
verfahren gegen zwei verdächtige unter
anderem den damaligen zuger svp
präsidenten markus willimann wurde
eingestellt
für die schweizer öffentlichkeit ist
ohnehin klar die schuldige ist ihm nahm
das spiel täglich rund 3000 artikel
erscheinen nach diesen geschehnissen
über sie in vielen davon wird gemutmaßt
dass yolanda einen seitensprung
vertuschen wenn 2015 sieht sie sich
deswegen gezwungen ihre politische
karriere an den nagel zu hängen
erst 2017 wendet sich das blatt
länderspiels hegglin geht in die
offensive und beginnt gegen verschiedene
medienhäuser und journalisten zu
prozessieren
außerdem gründete sie den verein netz
courage mit dem sie sich gegen hass im
netz engagiert
insbesondere gegen sexismus wenn man ist
einfach los mit diesem feld immer verein
von frauen welche nicht schweigen
möchten
ich danke besuchen sie wird so in der
schweiz zu einer feministischen kohle
ich möchte wissen woher sie die kraft
dazu nimmt welchen einfluss mito auf
ihre geschichte hatte und wie wir es in
zukunft als gesellschaft vermeiden
wieder die gleichen fehler zu machen
die schlimmsten artikel die über sie
geschrieben wurden hat yolanda spiels
hecking gesammelt was ich zu hause im
zug gewährt sie mir einen einblick in
ihren ordner der schande wenn ich mir
das so anschaue also auch die katzen
artikel und sieht eigentlich so aus es
wird sich eine ganze branche an einer
frau erteilen
ja genau so was für mich unverständlich
dass da auch frau und auch mitgemacht
haben aber es war ja so aber die hatten
irgendwie sonst ein problem glaube ich
aber all diese männer diesen augen
dieser augen menge weil ich über mich
geschrieben haben und gemutmaßt haben
was da passiert ist hinter dieser
geschlossenen türen man es war einfach
nur ekelhaft 240 artikel hat das
schweizer medienhaus ringier dass auch
die boulevardzeitung blick herausgibt
alleine über ihren fall geschrieben
schon ziemlich schnell wurde es zur
täterin gemacht natürlich alle waren von
der sportpresse von blick und sogar in
der seriösen presse im tages anzeiger es
ist schade allen frauen mit meiner haut
das ist
ich meine warum diese schlagzahl und das
ist das ist so winterlich ein näschen
für 48.000 frauen können es doch kraft
harmlosen das alles hauptsache man kann
die aufmerksamkeit der leser innen
gewinnen und die auflage steigen und da
wurde es so viel geld verdient mit
diesen diese art von schlagzeilen wie
kann so etwas so entgleisen
es hat die kontrollinstanz hat gefällt
es hat niemand die reißleine gezogen
es hat jemand menschen direkt zu was
irgendwie politik macht dem
regierungspräsidenten die hätten stopp
sagen können
stopp gesagt hat niemand von ihren
ehemaligen kolleginnen und kollegen im
zuger kantonsrat im gegenteil man
misstraut er öffentlich genauso wie dem
verdächtigen markus hörmann aus allen
parteien sogar von linken parteien und
der sp zum beispiel rechner mitgemacht
haben
die haben sich da vor die kamera
gedrängt und und rücktritte gefordert
anstatt einfach zu sagen das ist die
geschichte geht nicht immer nur darum
vertrauen und ehrlichkeit rede
wenn wir das immer im hinterkopf
federführung was da passiert ich glaube
die meisten liegt werde so dass man sich
würdig und sagt okay es ist für die es
ist passiert aber ich lebe gezogen sie
kämpfen tiefer das verstehe ich nicht
da haben wir wenn sie glüht nach mit aus
rheda und widersprüche der mediensektor
warnliste verantwortung ziehen was er
immer wieder hier auch durchdringt in
all diesen artikeln wird er dann auch
der vorwurf laut du hast diese
aufmerksamkeit dieses blitzlichtgewitter
diesen medien scheinwerferlicht auch
gesucht
es hat mir nichts mehr gewünscht aus
dass man mich in ruhe lassen hätte wir
mussten die kinder aus der schule nehmen
ich musste antidepressiva nehmen obwohl
ich stellte ein sehr fröhlicher mensch
war
ich kann mich nicht drum herum ich weiß
nicht ob ich sonst noch leben würde ich
denke die pharma-branche da habe ich
noch nicht viel er gerettet
noch viel wichtiger ist zu dieser zeit
aber die unterstützung ihres ehemanns
reto spies stand immer bedingungslos auf
der seite seiner frau und tut das bis
heute
er äußert sich nicht gern vor den medien
macht für uns aber eine ausnahme bei
einem kaffee in ihrer gemeinsamen
wohnung erzählt er mir warum er
journalistinnen gegenüber normalerweise
misstrauisch ist die journalisten die
mich kontaktiert haben dass man gang
eigentlich die bösen jene die jetzt tat
sind oder sich im strafverfahren
befinden
wir haben dann beispielsweise bei der
arbeit mich angerufen und sich um eine
stellungnahme gebeten das haben sie
natürlich sehr
mit viel charme für uns möglich war
versucht und mich zuerst freundlich
versucht zu können und dass ich da
abgelehnt habe haben sie mehr druck
gemacht und die letzte druckstufe war
dann zu sagen wenn sie nicht sagen
dann schreiben wir auch irgendeinen box
minister und so war es dann auch
gekommen
so stand der in der weltwoche ich war ja
ausgezogen aus der gemeinsamen wohnung
enthält ist die kinder gehört nach
mitgenommen
es ist sehr sehr schwer vorstellbar wenn
so eine lawine hereinbricht wie
funktioniert man da als familie weiter
man verliert schon auch ein stück weit
das urvertrauen dass man vielleicht
vorher raute und man merkt wie man da
einfach ins bodenlose stürzt
was ich dinge ereignen die man sich in
der schlimmsten träumen ich hätte
vorstellen können dass es zerstört schon
etwas
ich musste übrigens auch die die fenster
abdecken aus angst vor journalistinnen
die polizei politik partie und als ich
das so ein bisschen ja also die die
media kampagne hat fahrt aufgenommen
haben wir uns entschieden auf ärztlichen
rat hin dass wir entgegen für eine zeit
verlassen
ja das war die katastrophe ich habe da
wir klären zusammenbruch erlebt und tag
nach heiligabend und ja da musste ich
dann medizinische hilfe in anspruch
nehmen
wie ich aber der meinung da ist dann ja
eigentlich sehr schnell wieder auf die
beine gekommen und hat sehr schnell in
den
kämpfer modus geschaltet und ja sich
aufgerappelt und auch den rest der
familie damit gezogen
wann kam dann schließlich der wendepunkt
ich glaube für die öffentliche
wahrnehmung war es die das interview von
reto mit watson 2017 redet reto spies
abgesehen von heute das erste und
einzige mal öffentlich über seine frau
diese ist davon überzeugt das interview
hat zu einem umdenken über ihren fall
geführt
wie kam es zu diesem schlüssel interview
es war mir eigentlich von anfang an klar
dass der moment kommen wird wo wo ich in
die offensive gehen muss und auch wählen
und das schwierige war im richtigen
moment abzuwarten die richtige person
richtigen journalisten abzuwarten und es
dann zu platzieren nicht in hektik zu
verfallen und nach zweieinhalb jahren
war haben sie folgt dieser mann der
keine fixe vorstellungen hatte was genau
passiert ist selber offenbar konnte mit
diesem interview und auch akribischer
recherchearbeit eine gegend ausstellung
machen
so haben sie pro miene
der mann der das interview mit reto
spieß damals geführt hat heißt haben sie
folgt
[Musik]
er war drei jahre lang chefredakteur
beim schweizer online medium nutzen und
ist einer der wenigen journalisten der
bereits 2017 auch yolanda seite
beleuchtet hat ich besuche ihn zu hause
in sargans und sprechen mit ihm über die
rolle die wurzeln und er in die
landesgeschichte spielen
was hat man dieses interview mit den
ehemann von yolanda spielen verändert
wir haben das spiel hätte und das ist
die würde ja irgendwie manipuliert oder
irgendwie abgeklemmt
oder wenn sie irgendetwas versucht hat
würde das eher negativ dargestellt und
ich habe dann gesagt ich würde gerne mit
ihrem mann reden und jetzt kamerateams
sagen aha da kommt der mann und er redet
wieder nur mit dem mann und so weiter
und erst dann gilt es und ist
wahrscheinlich verblüffend wie viel mehr
wirken diese geschichte erzielt hat weil
der mann spricht also auffällig bei
diesem interview ist ja auch das sind
sehr sexistische fragen dabei
ich finde es total wichtig diese fragen
die ich mir nie stellen würde nach der
kürze des rocks oder im schulterfreien
kleidern oder sowas
das waren aber die fragen die die leute
in den köpfen hatten die musste die
stellen und unter anderem mit der sehr
unangenehmen frage ob er nicht manchmal
das gefühl hat sie soll doch endlich
ruhe geben dann hat er gesagt das finde
ich bis heute absolut großartig yolanda
kennt auf ihre weise
ich kämpfe er auf die ruhige weise aber
wir machen beide einfach solange dieses
gerecht ist und das mal statement hat
diese artikel in der medienszene dann zu
einem umdenken geführt
teils teils ich meine das ist ein
spiegel den mann der medienszene vorhält
und manche
fanden diesen spiegel ich sehr sehr
angenehm aber andere haben tatsächlich
angefangen zu sagen hey tatsächlich da
gibt es eine andere version was wir uns
da in unserem kopf kino irgendwie alles
damals ausgeräumt haben wir sind von der
falschen annahme ausgegangen und haben
sich verschiedene journalisten auch
öffentlich entschuldigt
dazu gehören zb erich aschwanden von der
neuen zürcher zeitung
[Musik]
komischerweise okay was sie sparen und
da passieren durften sind die artikel
schon wieder oder carmen epp von der
online news plattform zentral + ich
damals gewusst wie wichtig es ist dass
sich der raum das spiel the clean werden
alle medien kursiert sind hat mich
fertig geschrieben was hat diese
geschichte für mechanismen beginnt diese
geschichte hat natürlich alles was im
klassischen bulva über dienst vielleicht
noch mal zu definieren gilt wirklich
eine rolle spielt was als
erfolgsversprechend gelten würde
also diese ganze formel dicken tränen
tiere also quasi als diese ganze dieser
appell an die ganze emotionalität das
lese sich hier natürlich enorm vorhanden
nehmen wir vielleicht auch das kind beim
namen also mit solchen geschichten kann
man natürlich sehr viel geld verdienen
wie das macht man vielleicht 300000
franken im online- umsatz und dann
vielleicht noch einmal 600.000 700.000
im print als oben satz wasser ist man
relativ schnell bei einer runden million
bruttogewinn erzielt wurde allein mit
der berichterstattung über jolanta
spiels hätten
mich stimmt betroffen wie viel medien
damit verdient haben yolanda öffentlich
zu vernichten
gleichzeitig bin ich froh darüber dass
sich der ton der berichterstattung über
sie doch noch gewandelt hat das
interview mit reto spies hat dabei
sicher eine rolle gespielt
noch viel wichtiger dürfte aber ein
anderes ereignis gewesen sein
im oktober 2017 erschüttert mieten die
welt die schauspielerin alyssa milano
macht den hashtag populär unter dem
später hunderttausende von frauen ihre
erfahrungen mit sexueller gewalt in den
sozialen medien teilen werden
ausgelöst wird diese lawine durch den
skandal um den hollywood produzenten
harvey weinstein der von dutzenden von
frauen beschuldigt wurde sie sexuell
belästigt zu haben
darunter so berühmte schauspielerinnen
wie gwyneth paltrow und angelina jolie
[Musik]
löst endlich eine längst fällige
öffentliche debatte über sexuelle gewalt
aus und auch privat sprechen wir frauen
öfters über dieses thema mit
filmemacherin und freundin susanne
tausche ich mich zum beispiel regelmäßig
darüber aus need to die medienbranche
verändert hat und unser eigenes leben
ich habe gemerkt dass ich sehr sehr viel
verdrängt habe vor allem auch als
praktikantin was man da alles erlebt an
machtmissbrauch auch latente ausnutzung
der höheren position was man im
arbeitsleben und gerade auch im
mediensektor alles erlebt was mir auch
aufgefallen ist dass man früher auch
wirklich ganz viel erduldet hatten hat
weggesehen
man hat oft auch den journalisten oder
männern die praktikantinnen betreuung
übergeben die eben sehr anzügliche
sachen gesagt haben gemacht haben
da ich mich auch daran warum glaubst du
ist das so also frage ich mich einfach
ständig immer wieder sowieso hat es so
lange gedauert hat bis irgendwie dieser
aufschrei kam so also dass man halt
eigentlich vieles lernt sich selber
zuzuschreiben sich selbst kritisch zu
sehen die schuld eher bei sich zu suchen
meine ich bin aufgewachsen mit einem
musik sehr konservativ das gesehen hat
die auch gesagt hat jetzt gehst du ins
gymnasien in der stadt und da die so
sicher keine kurzen röcke an
sonst passiert hier was verantwortung
liegt ja auch bei den frauen nicht
möchtest dass dir etwas passiert dann
sollst du dann verhalten anpassen das
wird ihr als frau beigebracht aber ich
hab das nie irgendwie erlebt dass mein
bruder gesagt worden wäre so hey so egal
wie eine frau gekleidet ist das darfst
du nicht tun dass es eigentlich nie
passiert so in meiner erinnerung in
meiner kindheit und die welt ist einfach
so man hat es akzeptiert die mechanismen
sind zog und man hat sich das auch schön
geredet als war oft der ist halt so
charmant alte schule das macht man halt
noch so glaubst du mit den frauen ihren
vorteil gebracht wirklich es hat unter
den frauen eine solidarisierung mit sich
gebracht ich finde die scham die
irgendwie mit solchen geschichten
einhergeht es ist kleiner geworden
also ist auch mutiger und
selbstbewusster geworden dadurch ja auf
jeden fall eine der frauen die dafür
verantwortlich ist dass die diskussion
über sexuelle gewalt überhaupt ins
rollen kam ist die deutsche aktivistin
annie zurück sie organisierte zum
beispiel die berliner slot box an denen
tausende von frauen für ihre sexuelle
selbstbestimmung demonstrierten und sie
lancierte den hashtag auf schreibt auf
twitter
quasi der deutsche vorläufer von nico
[Musik]
2013 wurde sie dafür mit dem grimme
online award ausgezeichnet einem
renommierten deutschen medienpreis
[Musik]
das ist patricia die mit das interview
mit ihr führen freut mich sehr
dich wird zwar einmal kennenzulernen was
stecken für erfahrungen hinter dem
hashtag auch partie persönlich also ich
habe längst nicht alles geteilt was ich
eine erfahrung selber schon nach musste
aber habe unter anderem darüber
geschrieben hab ich eben als studenten
von dem professor bei dem ich in meiner
sprechstunde war das übliche frage auch
gestellt bekommen hatte wo ich dann auch
später heraus bekommen habe dass er
sozusagen schon bekannt dafür ist auch
gerne sich junge gut aussehende
studentin irgendwie dann als hilfskräfte
zu organisieren und dergleichen
ansonsten hat sich unter dem hashtag
will ich die ganze bandbreite an
sexismus und sexualisierter gewalt
gezeigt also von der bemerkung in der
schule wie madame sagt ja mädchen können
ja eh kein mathe hinzu man wird beim
ausgehen irgendwie begrapscht nachts
verfolgt aber auch sexuelle übergriffe
innerhalb der familie zum beispiel
wurden geschildert du kennst ja auch in
verschiedenen fronten quasi also sehr
viele initiativen und projekte zb da war
diese netz ohne gewalt aktion mit sehr
vielen expertinnen und politikerinnen
auch um was ging es dabei
mir war das wichtig da menschen
zusammenzubringen die zum thema digitale
gewalt zusammenarbeiten aber auch vor
allem nicht aus dem blick verlieren dass
da auch geschlechtsspezifische gewalt
noch mal eine große rolle spielt also
wir möchten damit einfach auch ein
statement setzen das digitale gewalt
noch viel größer ist als dieses was sag
ich jetzt mal unter diesem begriff hass
im netz
mitunter kursiert also die häusliche
gewalt oder auch die gewalt nach einer
trennung in der beziehung wird immer
häufiger auch mit hilfe von digitalen
medien ausgeübt da werden dann checken
die weißes benutzt da wären vielleicht
bilde die zuerst im einverständnis
geteilt wurden miteinander vielleicht
auch nacktbilder dann entsprechend
unerlaubt verbreitet also auch das ist
digitale gewalt und dieses feld ist
einfach sehr viel größer als sozusagen
nur die kommentare die wir gerade sehr
starken fokus haben und weshalb ist die
dieser kampf gegen hass im netz gegen
digitale gewalt eine gesellschaftliche
aufgabe es ist ja so dass internet kann
ja nur so gut sein wie die menschen die
es benutzen und wenn es missbraucht wird
um menschen wiederum zu stocken zu
bedrohen ihnen ja auch wirklich
psychisches und am ende damit auch ein
körperliches leid zuzufügen dann ist das
etwas was er ganz klar adressieren
müssen in der schweiz kämpft
länderspiels hegglin gegen hass im netz
wie sie ihre geschichte sie leistet da
wirklich gerade pionieren arbeit finde
ich also gerade was die ganze diskussion
rund um digitale gewalt angeht aber
natürlich auch umgang mit medien mit
frauen und wie sexismus in der branche
sich auch noch heraus wirkt und was das
für die berichterstattung gerade auch
zum sexualisierter gewalt dann auch mal
heißt dann kann ich nur hoffen dass das
genug menschen auch wertschätzen wieder
sie da gemacht
2017 ist das wendejahr füreinander
spiels hätten
danach geht sie in die offensive und
beginnt gegen sexistische
berichterstattung und den hass der er in
den sozialen medien entgegenschlägt zu
kämpfen
[Musik]
sie verklagt unter anderem das
medienhaus ringier dass die zeitung blic
heraus liebt ihr name hätte in der
allerersten schlagzeile über anfang 2014
nicht genannt werden dürfen
[Musik]
wie wichtig war es die juristisch
vorzugehen
ob somit wichtige ich glaube die stärke
die ich jetzt in mir trage die habe ich
gewonnen durch diese wichtigen
juristischen siege es gab eine zeit da
glaube ich nicht mehr an den rechtsstaat
und dies wieder zu spüren dass das
system funktioniert das war ich mich was
vom wichtigsten und der absolut
wichtigste sieg war bis jetzt natürlich
schon diese gegen die niederlande spies
hecking ringt gegen den blick einen
teilsieg die zeitung habe mit ihrer
berichterstattung die
persönlichkeitsrechte der ehemaligen
zuger kantonsrat in widerrechtlich
verletzt
die geschichte von julian des spiels
hegglin bild vieles in mir auf wenn ich
aufgewühlt bin dann male ich dunkle
gejagte bilder denn auch ich habe
bereits erfahrung mit sexistischer
berichterstattung machen müssen wie das
damals war erzähle ich was an
ja ich hab halt gemerkt dass ging in den
köpfen wenig zusammen kommt eine junge
attraktive frau und die erzählt uns was
über wirtschaft und da habe ich schon
von anfang an meiner karriere immer
kommentaren briefe erhalten was will mir
diese barbie fund wirtschaft und
börsenkursen erzählen was macht sie da
die versteht ja nix
ich bin ökonom in und haben jetzt hart
arbeitet und auch härter arbeitet als
männliche kollegen oder andere
moderatoren die haben gar nicht
wirtschaft studiert wir hatten halt
graue haare und diesen dialog der ihnen
an kompetenz verlieren hat mehr als
eigentlich ein studium zum fachgebiet
und das hat mich schon seit jeher
verfolgt leider auch die presse hat das
auch immer so gesehen es ging nur um den
jugend waren den schönheitswahn des srf
wie lange ist das denn her
es ist noch nicht lange her dass drei
jahre her da war gar nicht so was ja
nicht 16
klar das ist ein jugend waren dass
weitere probleme die jugend waren auch
da habe ich entschieden dass ich mich
wehren möchte ich habe anwälten
angerufen und gesagt so geht es nicht
und die hat natürlich klappt gesagt die
müssen sich entschuldigen die müssen das
korrigieren da gehen wir jetzt dagegen
vor und verlangen dass alles das folgt
dann auch wirklich die berichtigung mit
dem richtigen berufsbezeichnung und im
hintergrund und den kompetenzen und auch
eine entschuldigung
[Musik]
die anwältin die mir damals geholfen hat
ist trainer zulauf sie ist die schweizer
medien rechtsanwältin und vertritt auch
yolanda spiels hecking vor gericht
ich besuche sie in ihrer kanzlei in
zürich und möchte von ihr wissen welche
weiteren verfahren sie und julian
dagegen linie anstrebt zweiter ist jetzt
angestrengt haben geht es darum dass der
gewinn den ring ag erwirtschaftet hat
irland des spiels hegglin zugesprochen
wird
je mehr klicks ein beitrag generiert
desto mehr werbung können sie um diesen
beitrag platzieren beste mehr gewinnen
können ein medienunternehmen generieren
und das hat eine fatale folge weil
insbesondere beten beiträge klicken die
schockierende skandalisieren des
abstruses bringen
bei ihrer an des spiels hecking war es
beispielsweise so einer der
meistgeklickten beitrag datis was
geschah hinter dieser tür und man kommt
auf diese tür klicken und dieser
versuchung hierzu klicken und zu sehen
was geschieht jetzt da dahinter sind
jetzt da zwei gerade mitten im akt das
löst ein reflex aus bei vielen menschen
und sie klicken auf diesen artikel das
heißt mit wenig journalistischem aufwand
können sie heute unglaublich
erfolgreiche abdeckt los die haben im
recht bislang sehr wenig rechtsprechung
zum thema gewinn herausgabe deswegen
sind wir hier wohl derjenige fall der
mutmaßlich wegweisend werden könnte
hatte sie erstaunt so ein erfahrenes
medienunternehmen wie er in je das jetzt
so weit gegen in der berichterstattung
es hat mich leider gottes nicht erstaunt
ich glaube das war ganz einfach konzil
landes spiels hegglin hat gut geklappt
also ich glaube beim blick gehört dieses
risiko das einkalkuliert wird letztlich
bedauerlicherweise zum geschäftsmodell
ringe hat sich zwar öffentlich bioland
des spiels hegglin entschuldigt das
geschäftsmodell könnte aber so oder so
bald veraltet sein wenn sie auch ihren
nächsten prozess gegen ringier gewinnt
muss ihr das medienhaus den gewinn aus
bezahlen denn es mit ihr gemacht hat und
wenn das passiert haben
medienunternehmen in der schweiz in
zukunft keinen anreiz mehr mit solchen
geschichten geld zu verdienen
das könnte die medienbranche in der
schweiz dramatisch verändern das reicht
aber längst nicht findet yolanda denn
sie hat auch in den sozialen medien viel
hass erfahren müssen wir frauen wissen
wenn wir uns wehren schlägt uns oft
große wut entgegen
du hast ja sehr viel erlebt in puncto
haus gibt es dennoch noch botschaften
die dich selber immer noch erschüttern
also wirklich wirklich mit dem hab ich
diese nachricht da wünscht mir jemand
den tod ganz klar aber auch meinen
kindern und beschreibt ganz detailliert
war sehr mit den kindern machen wird
bevor sie dann sterben ein mensch habt
sowas geschrieben und findet das ist so
und das das macht mich natürlich angst
es ist anna lieben es kann jeder sein es
kann irgendwie mein nachbar sein
theoretisch und es gibt auch nachrichten
die einen bezug auf mich auf meine
kleider die ich an einem tag trage
beschreiben dann was ich mich aus
gesehen habe welche farbe mein t shirt
hat um zu es war so dass das ein
anonymer facebook-account war der wurde
eigens erstellt um diese bruni zu
schicken und die staatsanwaltschaft die
konnte nichts machen ja und zwar ein
rechtshilfegesuch gestellt aber ich
glaube gar keine antwort bekommen von
facebook und das ist eigentlich das
tragische mann ist wirklich sehr sehr
ausgeliefert diese konzerne machen was
sie wollen
sie verdienen so viel geld aber müssen
sich nicht an die schweizer gesetze
halten
in österreich ist dies nun anders dort
wurde im dezember 2020 ein gesetzespaket
gegen hass im netz verabschiedet dieses
macht es einerseits für die opfer
leichter sich zu wehren andererseits
nimmt es auch kommunikations plattformen
wie facebook und co in die pflicht
treibende kraft hinter dem gesetz war
die grüne politikerin und nationalrätin
siege maurer
sie treffe ich in ihrem arbeitsort
button grünen in wien und lasse mir das
gesetzespaket noch einmal im detail
erklären sie sind zwei verschiedene
gesetzes teile das eine ist das
kommunikations plattformen gesetzt da
geht es darum dass facebook twitter und
co in die pflicht genommen werden dass
die ansprechpartner haben im land das
direkt geklagt werden kann wenn man
etwas dem klagen hat das meldesystem
eingerichtet werden müssen und auch das
profil gelöscht werden müssen
und das zweite ist dass im zivilrecht
möglichkeiten geschaffen wurden das
tatsächlich leichter geklappt werden
kann
habt ihr jetzt durch das dann eines der
strengsten gesetze europa wahrheit gegen
hass rede
wir haben jedenfalls ein gesetzespaket
das auf beiden seiten als auf seiten der
kommunikations plattformen als auch auf
seiten der betroffenen wo wir die
betroffenen rechte und den schutz der
betroffenen massiv ausgebaut haben haben
wir sicher das beste gesetz würde ich
sagen ja
also wenn ich mir so probieren anschauen
und man sieht dass eben wirklich auch um
lang gewartet sich auch im offline
gewalt überschwappen kann dann frage ich
mich schon und ich verstehe es bis heute
noch nicht woher kommt diese tiefe wut
gegenüber fahren
naja es ist ja auch nichts neues also es
ist vieles was sich auf facebook über
nachrichten bekommen wird am stammtisch
genauso ausgesprochen
ich komme ursprünglich aus tirol
zaleski tourismus und was dort in den
diskurs herum gebrüllt wird das ist
unerträglich und das ist kein neues
phänomen als oder hass entsteht ja nicht
weil es das netz gibt sondern das ist
schon da was glaube ich schon dazu kommt
ist dass die gesellschaft sich insgesamt
verändert frauen werden nicht mehr so
eindeutig auf einen platz geschoben
sie wehren sich sie sind laut sie haben
plötzlich ähnliche privilegien wie die
männer und das ist natürlich
machtverlust und damit tun sich viele
männer schwer dass sie sich jetzt nicht
mehr nur weil sie männer sind schon eine
bessere stellung in der gesellschaft
sichern können
das ist offensichtlich für viele
bedrohlich sie genau was politisches
engagement gegen hass im netz basiert
auf eigenen erfahrungen 2018 erhält sie
von facebook account eines lina bier
lokals eine obszöne nachricht oder
klarer eine vergewaltigung stroop kurz
nachdem sie an eben diesem lokal vorbei
gegangen war
sie veröffentlichte die nachricht mit
samt im namen des ladenbesitzers auf
facebook er zeigte sie infolgedessen
wegen übler nachrede und
kreditschädigung an
[Musik]
erstinstanzlich wurde sie genauer aus
schuldig gesprochen und zu einem bußgeld
von insgesamt 7000 euro verurteilt
der richter glaubte ihr zwar allerdings
habe sie nicht beweisen können dass
tatsächlich der ladenbesitzer die
nachricht geschrieben habe
zweitinstanzlich wurde das mutterland
zwar aufgehoben
der schock sitzt bei siggi maurer aber
immer noch tief sie nehmen mich mit zum
landesgericht für strafsachen in wien an
den ort an den sie verurteilt wurde weil
sie sich gewehrt hatte
seekirchen alle wissen dass nach den weg
gemacht
ja ich glaube drei vier fünf mal fünf
mal hier hast du erstinstanzlich
verurteilt was hast du den momente da
ich bin am zweiten prozesstag dann
schuldig gesprochen worden
da habe ich gedacht das gibts doch wohl
nicht aber auch gedacht gut dann gehalt
bis zum europäischen gerichtshof es sein
muss und ja also es hat sich gezogen
über zweieinhalb jahre waren mehrere
zehntausend euro dieser prozess gekostet
hat es ist jetzt so dass der kläger
eigentlich die kosten übernehmen muss
ich gehe leider davon aus dass es nicht
sein kann dass das alles selber gezahlt
selbstverständlich zurück denkt hat sich
das gelohnt also ob die lohnt und ich
haben ja nicht ausgesucht dass ich
verklagt werde dafür dass sie mit gegen
hass im netz wäre aber ich würde sagen
in der gesamtheit der geschichte ist es
gut ausgegangen es hat zwar sehr viel
geld gekostet aber wir haben großes
gesetzespaket gegen hass im netz auf den
weg bringen können
und es gibt einen rechtshilfefonds für
andere betroffene von hass im netz mit
dem sie unterstützt werden wenn sie
klaren möchten
und ich glaube insgesamt ist die ons für
das thema einfach sehr gestiegen und
auch die akzeptanz von hass im netz
deutlich gesucht
im fall von siggi maurer ist aus einem
schlimmen erlebnis eine neue
gesetzgebung gegen hass im netz
entstanden
ende gut alles gut könnte man meinen nur
in deutschland und in der schweiz sieht
es ganz anders aus als in österreich
hier hinken die gesetze noch immer stark
hinter dem realen leben im digitalen
zeitalter hier
und genau hier setzt die landes spiels
hecklingen mit ihrem projekt netz
courage an
seit 2016 kämpft sie mit dem verein
gegen hass im netz
insbesondere gegen sexismus aber auch
gegen alle anderen formen von
diskriminierung
sie leistet soforthilfe für die opfer
und betreibt aufklärungs und
präventionsarbeit bereits mehrfach wurde
sie für ihre arbeit ausgezeichnet auch
in deutschland waren sind frauen so viel
mehr betroffen als männer
ich glaube in den augen vieler männer
sind frauen haut wirklich noch nicht auf
der gleichen ebene vielem einheit zu
haben glaube ich nicht bestanden dass
frauen dieselben rechte haben dass ihr
die gleichstellung eigentlich leben
sollten also viele dieser heute die
nutzen die sozialen medien hat auch um
diesen auch so auszuleben weil ich das
vielleicht zu hause nicht mehr können
als sie dauern die schranken gewiesen
werden oder im restaurant am stammtisch
zum beispiel wie es nicht mehr so
goutiert aber online auf den sozialen
medien
da hat sie keine keine barriere
ich mache von allem und das habe ich mir
angewöhnt screenshots sofort bevor ich
eben was anderes machen noch ich immer
einen screenshot der wird sofort
gespeicherte auf einem externen services
zwischen 50.000 screenshots glaube ich
sind da schon drauf danach lief des
hasses ja es ist wahrscheinlich die
größte last datenbank der schweizer
glaube ich gibt es auch bekannte
prominente frauen die sich bei ihr
melden
ja das gibt's was ich stehe nicht unter
schweigepflicht glaube ich aber ich sehe
auch nicht mit namen aber ich habe auch
schon eine bundesrätin beraten
das gibt zum das sind wirklich nicht
einfach linke frauen sind bürgerliche
und auch bürgerliche menschen das sind
sie aus und das sind auch migranten ja
einfach alles gepasst im netz trifft
kannst du mir auch ein beispiel geben
von einem ganz bekannten fall ja also
ein fall welches großes aufsehen erregt
auch in der presse dann auch als ein
pariser frauen bhs verbrannt haben
das war ein feministisches symbolen das
hat wahnsinnig viele alte männer
geprügelt
[Musik]
gemeinsam mit der damaligen präsidentin
der schweizer jungsozialisten tamara von
itella erstattete julian des spiels
hecking rund 40 mal anzeige daraufhin
wurden über 20 männer verurteilt
und das geht dann so ein kleiner
aufschrei sinnvoll passt auf wir werden
beobachtet wir werden angezeigt wir
dürfen uns jetzt nicht mehr alles
leisten was wir hier noch täglich
gemacht haben
ja ich glaub kommst mir auch ein
bisschen mehr noch hinschauen ich glaube
auch die politik habe das noch nicht
ganz verstanden was soziale medien hat
auch für eine kraft habe nicht nur die
kraft der sozialen medien ist groß
sondern auch jene von yolanda spiels
hackling wie sie es geschafft hat sich
wie ein phönix aus der asche aus den
trümmern ihres lebens zu erheben das
möchte ich wissen und woher nimmt sie
die kraft sich jeden tag mit so viel
hass zu beschäftigen
ich finde ein geschichte ich sie erlebt
haben darf sich nicht wiederholen das
darf nie mehr so etwas passieren
ich will dass meine tochter so was nicht
erlebt und auch ihre freundinnen nicht
und deswegen braucht seine aufarbeitung
der geschehnisse
eine ungerechtigkeit löst so viel aus
und lässt einem eigentlich viel
gewachsen
irgendwann kann man fliegen die
mannschaft man dinge die man mit
schaffen würden wenn das ist so schlimm
gewesen
wenn jemand alles hinter uns haben
wenn dann auch die kinder nicht mehr in
der schule sind wieder das freie sind
dann gehen wir den weg
dort wo uns noch niemand kennt und dort
irgendwie das leben neu beginnen
das ist so ein bisschen der wurm ist
dann hatte sie noch aus glaube ich
was für mich von den geschichten von
anne wieczorek siege maurer und jolanda
spiels hecking bleibt ist ein gefühl der
hoffnung
ich weiß so wie wohl alle anderen frauen
auch ganz genau wie schlimm sich
sexismus und hassan fühlen und trotzdem
bringen uns diese erfahrungen auch näher
zusammen wenn wir sie denn miteinander
teilen
das wissen dass wir nicht alleine sind
und dass wir gemeinsam viel erreichen
können im kampf um eine gerechtere welt
machen
[Musik]
das waren die geschichten kämpferische
frauen
wir haben aber auch noch mit anderen
starken menschen gesprochen
ein film dreht sich um frauen und macht
unter anderem um frauen und pornografie
ihr seht die videos recht eingeblendet